to that end democrats have now
subpoenaed multiple former trump
advisers and white house staffers one of
them includes chief of staff mark
meadows and he's tried to comply at this
point he's using
executive privilege he joins us now now
he's written a terrific new book i've
read it cover to cover i love it it's on
amazon.com if you want a first edition
copy it's in bookstores everywhere as of
today and on hannity.com the chiefs
chief mark meadows is with us
uh let's start with january 6. did
donald trump
want now this is the same donald trump
that said many of you will now
peacefully and patriotically
march to the capitol so your voices may
be heard that same guy
did he or did he not
ask for the national guard knowing that
there would be big crowds in d.c
beforehand
well uh sean you've reported on this
before you know it doesn't get much
attention i can tell you that uh
not only did donald trump want to make
sure the national guard was available uh
he repeated that a number of times and i
think that there are a number of people
that he's communicated with that can
back me up on that particular
assessment you know in addition to that
we can all condemn what happened on
january 6th and and rightfully so
but i'm not aware of anybody in the west
wing that had any advanced knowledge
that the security was going to be
breached at the capitol
that being said as you mentioned uh
the the january 6 commission is
continuing on
we've been trying to work with them in a
spirit of accommodation to actually
share
what we know from a non-privileged
standpoint while making sure that
executive privilege is protected the
president has claimed executive
privilege i'm going to honor that i'm
not going to be the first
chief of staff to to actually waive that
it's not mine to wave and uh and it's
really not congress is to wave so
unfortunately
because liz cheney is joining with
others
and they're talking about holding you in
criminal contempt
as early as tomorrow your reaction
well obviously they're going to have to
do what what they do and and they're a
separate body i i can tell you that
we've tried to work with the committee
to provide them and even offered them
other options in terms of answering
questions that if this is got a true
legislative intent we want to help them
fix the problem where it never happens
again but i i can tell you that
you know they've been pretty aggressive
about holding people in contempt and and
uh you know they'll do what they need to
do and and
at this point hopefully the courts can
work it out yeah when they kicked off
jim jordan and jim banks it was a
predetermined outcome and liz cheney's
mission is to align with the very people
that called her father a murderer a war
criminal and a crook to
to align herself with those people and
the worst foreign policy in american
history with more weakness one of the
things i really liked about the book and
i know other things got
you know the false positive and you were
clear about that on covet it was so
stupid the way the media covered it but
more importantly you bring us inside the
white house in a very different way all
these than all these anti-trump books
and you speak glowingly of a president
that works round the clock never stops
and kept his promises and it worked for
the country as we now have learned in
the last 11 months
well it works for the country because he
was working 24 hours a day seven days a
week i mean he was working me under the
table but more importantly than that you
know you have this lead in about what
we're seeing with russia in in ukraine
i can tell you it was a leader in
president trump who was strong he didn't
say change your expectation he says live
up to your expectation and what happened
is vladimir putin has changed his
expectation he expects weakness from the
oval office and so that's made him far
more aggressive it's well beyond just
nordstrom 2. it it really goes to the
foreign policy initiative that we're
seeing coming out of the white house and
sadly it is very weak
two things i think define the trump
presidency and you capture this in the
book a guy that made promises and kept
them but also a guy that was tough with
china and russia and iran and i do
believe that the world believed donald
trump would act if provoked i don't
think that exists today
well without a doubt they knew that he
would act the other thing is is when it
was candidate donald trump they were all
concerned that we would be on the
doorstep of a war if it was president
donald trump not only did he uh strike a
peace deal par historic peace deals uh
we didn't have to worry about uh a new
war because he was willing to show the
might of the american people in every uh
situation and and candidly uh
you know i miss those days yeah well the
book's phenomenal uh as i said in
bookstores as of today the chief's chief
it's also on amazon.com if you want a
first edition
print copy and hannity.com as well
mark we'll have you back on to talk more
about it thank you for being with us hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else